nous sommes à amariyah tel falloudja
dans la province d'anbar
si seulement 45 kilomètres séparent
bagdad de la position la plus rapprochée
du groupe armé état islamique
nous accompagnons les hommes chargés de
stopper sa progression vers la capitale
d'emblée il est clair que le i n'a pas
l'intention de s'arrêter
d'après sport ne tarde pas à entrer dans
la bataille
il n'y est proche
le barrage de tirs prometic une
communication interceptée annonce une
pluie de mortiers instant à l'autre de
la part de lui il y en a pour tous de
quitter
de retour à la base d'opérations de la
brigade un peu en retrait du brouillard
de la guerre à bouquin serre explique ce
qui s'est passé là où nous étions de 200
à 250 mètres nous séparer de l'ennemi
leur caméra nous ont détecté et ils ont
attaqué nos véhicules croyant que nous
lancions une offensive à bouquin serre
et ses hommes combattent lui depuis 14
mois déjà mais ils ne font pas partie de
la meilleure à cayenne notre combat est
idéologique et religieux nous ne sommes
pas une armée qui reçoit des ordres et
nous sommes prêts à combattre aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra
déjà 53 des volontaires de la brigade
and sara lemar jahia sont morts dans
cette guerre ils ont été parmi les tout
premiers à répondre à la fatwa lancée
par le grand ayatollah ali sistani en
juin de l'an dernier appelant tous les
musulmans apte au combat à prendre les
armes contre lui
hamid al yassiri un imam qui enseigne
dans une madrassa une école religieuse
de najaf commandes les quelque 2500
combattants de la brigade
nous avons demandé à être aux premières
lignes
l'armée est derrière nous à l'armée
irakienne est une grande armée mais elle
a perdu confiance en eux des milices
populaires voulons lui redonner cette
confiance c'est grâce à l'intervention
du commandant al yassiri que nous avons
pu visiter les positions tenues par
l'armée irakienne dans le secteur ce
qu'on nous refusait jusque là en route
on peut entendre les conversations radio
entre les combattants de l'udps qui
s'informent de nos mouvements
à la limite josiane à paris à 10h
l'espion diack route répond
aïe aïe
retrancher derrière un talus
les soldats de la 17e brigade de l'armée
irakiennes font le guet eu aussi ces
soldats de l'armée irakienne assure la
garde arrière de la brigade dan sarel
marque dia
ils ont à peine 20 ans pour certains et
deux mois d'entraînement militaire ils
disent avoir récemment reçu de nouvelles
âmes de la part de la coalition ce qui
les aide dans leur lutte contre le
groupe armé état islamique
mais comme partout nous avons visité des
positions militaires on nous répète la
même chose si vous voulez qu'on fasse
plus et plus vite il faut nous aider
plus et plus souvent pour compenser
l'inexpérience des soldats qu'ils
dirigent le lieutenant-colonel mahmoud
doua souvent lui même mettre la main à
la pâte
si il doit intervenir pour mener une
frappe hors donné par son commandement
lui est un ennemi cruel
nous avons besoin d'une volonté
internationale pour l'éradiquer nous
avons besoin de plus de frappes
aériennes dossiers logistiques et
d'armes sophistiquées le sentiment que
la coalition internationale manque d'une
réelle volonté de vaincre lui est
partagé par le commandant rami qui va
même plus loin en halo late bottled to
ride
les états unis veulent que la bataille
se poursuivre la paix et la tranquillité
ne servent pas leurs intérêts ils
veulent se retrouver en sommet de la
pyramide et pour y arriver ils ont
besoin des guerres entre les milices
populaires et la coalition la méfiance
est partagé le problème c'est que la
coalition ne souhaite pas directement en
tout cas appuyer ces groupes armés
soutenus par l'iran
n'empêche ces milices chiites
représentent encore la majorité des
troupes au sol
en lieu et place de l'armée irakienne
qui tarde à se remettre de sa déroute de
l'an passé le religieux devenu
commandant militaire croient qu'il
reviendra à la prochaine génération de
poursuivre la guerre
1 al ahrar personnellement je crois que
l'irak ne sera pas en paix au cours de
cette décennie et même la prochaine
mohamed son fils de 8 ans qui garde à
ses côtés n'a jamais connu un pays en
paix
par média tu je veux quelques autos
jihane qu'ils se rappellent plus tard
que son bateau militaire s'est fait dans
une guerre pour défendre l'humanité et
sa nation baba de hollande n'est pas
trop tôt croit son père pour le préparer
à prendre le relais